it's great to welcome back to the
program after
too long of a hiatus scott barry kaufman
who's a
humanistic psychologist exploring the
depths of human potential
he's author of the book transcend the
new science of self-actualization uh
it's great to have you back on
thanks it's great to talk to you again
that was a fun one last time so
so let's uh i i have a feeling this one
will will also be so
two words in the title of your book
which we should just directly get into
because they can mean
different things to different people
transcendence
first of all and self-actualization what
what do you mean
in your use of those words what what is
self-actualization and what are we
looking to transcend
you know i think there's uh i just want
to start off with that see i think there
can be a lot of wisdom in the woo
and i but i've been trying to
scientifically put this on a foundation
that's grounded in as much evidence as
possible
so abraham maslow the humanistic
psychologist who
really was a big inspiration for me in
writing this book viewed
self-actualization as whatever
that unique part of you uh that uh that
really
makes you come alive that makes you
creative um that really shows
the world and uh that you truly existed
you know when when you were here on this
planet
uh transcendence which is something that
that mazzo tours the the
later years of his life really felt was
missing from his hierarchy of needs
he he saw it as a great connectedness to
others having
being at one with your values but
these what he called the b values the
values of being
itself so values which are no longer
means to another end
you know you've transcended uh having
values that are
uh that are perhaps selfishly oriented
but really
get outside of yourself is your um sense
that as you have worked in this field
now
for some time and you of course are
familiar with the history of it and
where the field is now
is your sense that there there will ever
really be
an achievement of what a lot of these
processes point to
or is it more this idea that the journey
really
is the process and there is no end point
at which we say
self-actualization has now happened and
and we're done
transcendence has happened and we're
done oh gosh what a
boring life that would be if you just if
you reach transcendence and then you
were done
right well you just what watch netflix
watch
uh binge watch cobra kai the rest of
your life
i guess yeah no i i'm all about the
process really and
i actually define uh the process of
becoming a whole person
a never-ending process it's a process of
integration
your con just constantly things we have
to integrate we are integrating
various warring factions within
ourselves but it's a never-ending
process
integrating worrying factions outside of
ourselves as well i mean we have
various viewpoints and other people
various viewpoints and
these days everyone wants to rip their
head off
that having this sense of um
of a north star of self-actualization or
having a north star of transcendence
means that you're always uh moving
towards
it's like you know you're never gonna
you can see the moon you can walk try to
walk towards the moon you're never gonna
walk to the moon i mean maybe someday
we'll be able to get to the moon
by other means but you know what just
having that self-actualization or
transcendence as this this
this moon that you always see in front
of you and that you're working towards i
think is a great north star to have
but it doesn't make any sense that
you're going to actually achieve it
one of the things that's common in
philosophy and
you know reading the theory of different
philosophers
this doesn't apply to all but it applies
to many it's the idea that a particular
um philosophical approach to life
is almost like a grand theory in the
sense that it is the
explanation for uh how things came to be
the way they are or how humans should
interact with the world or
it it purports to be a sort of
self-contained package that tells you
not everything you need to know in a
literal sense but
in terms of an approach to living covers
a lot of the ground
it seems to me and correct me if i'm
wrong that
you have a sort of different approach
that there is no such
one prescription so to speak
that's right i mean i i cringe quite
frankly when i see a lot of things in
the self-development space
and not i cringe for one reason they're
they're so out of touch with science and
um the actual evidence you you might
have some hyper narcissistic gurus or
something who
uh or uh or people who are trying to
sell a product
who because they thought of it you know
then they're like oh it's brilliant
but but the way science works is that i
i had so many ideas in grad school for
instance that i
woke up in the middle of the night oh
i'm brilliant it's brilliant and i
presented it to my advisor and i got a
reality check
you know it was like actually that's
doesn't make any damn sense
you know so so you know being a
scientist means you need that humility
right and so i think that the best way
forward
uh is to understand that different their
individual differences you know i i've
studied personality science and
you realize that people are on different
paths of self-actualization
we need to be as accepting as we can of
other people's
uh this might sound but sacred journey
you know i mean there's a sacred aspect
to each person
you know that's what maslow's trying to
get at with self-actualization he said
we don't try to change
roses into lilies we try to make a rose
into a good rose
and you know i think that that's that's
really the philosophy behind this is
that you need to find out what works for
you
uh you need to find out what what path
fits your unique constitution your
unique talents you need strengths you
need personality
you know what you see these days is
there a lot of people who are trying to
tell other people how they should live
their life
and it uh it's really it's really truly
unfortunate
i want to get to how much of this is
about the individual
but how much of it is the context in
which the individual lives meaning
society on planet earth at a particular
point in time
but to open that conversation um
we hear a lot about you know social
media
makes people less happy because you're
constantly comparing your life to the
lives of others
technology shorter attentions you know
there's this idea that
things are really bad right now in terms
of happiness because of particular
characteristics about society today
how would you answer the question of
whether people on balance are less happy
today than they were at some point in
the past
well you know if you look at every
generation no one is ever happy
in the history of the human species
there's always been
uh i mean there's been obviously uh
prosperous times
um and there's been droughts there's
been uh horrible times right now we're
you know we're going through a historic
moon right now which
you know 500 years from now they'll
probably talk about it as a really
difficult time
but but it is too part of human nature
to never be content
to never be satisfied to always um
strive for more to always be unsatisfied
with
the attainment of our basic needs now
there are
few people who really can cultivate a
really deep
mindfulness practice who cultivate a
really um
a practice where they're seeking wisdom
and and the wisdom they
are seeking is that enoughness you know
but
i do think it's it's part of human eater
every generation you know you have
uh you have people complaining you know
it's not like uh
it's that unique you know there's
there's some people had argued that
this is the narcissistic generation you
know that but then
and then there's some criticism that
came out well actually you know
every generation of it's just kids are
narcissistic
you know like unless you eradicate from
the gene pool you know
youth you're not going to eradicate
narcissism
to a large degree there's there's
certain things that are reoccurring
because they're part of human nature
what do you make of the uh i would not
what do you make of but
how should the average person who's
trying to figure out their path to deal
with
the the very present conflicts that
exist between
different philosophies and ideas so so
just like one example
the mindfulness movement has has become
very
uh and vogue over the last 10 to 15
years
and um meditation as
part of the path to self-actualization
and transcendence is something that
many people are talking about on the
other hand if you look
at the ancient stoic philosophers like
seneca and marcus aurelius and others
they are not so big necessarily on
meditation
in the sense of clearing the mind
and sort of sort of focusing on
breathing and the like and they have a
different approach
about sort of the practical steps that
someone might take
to solve some of the uh
issues that we might look to meditation
for help with it seems to be
sort of a conflict at least to some
degree how can the average person
navigate
with that as one example and of course
hundreds of others
the conflicts between these different
ideas about how to live
presently and and transcend for lack of
a better term
well it's a great question and i think
it goes back to your earlier question
about
uh is there one way to live a good life
i
taught at columbia i taught this course
the science of living well
and i had a whole history lecture where
i
go through in depth different
conceptualizations
of what the good life entails throughout
the course of human history
and my goal for my students is to see
what resonates with them the most i mean
you do you have the
you know the ryan holidays uh um i love
that guy you know i um
i talked he's been on my podcast a lot
of times and he
he's gung-ho about the stuff about the
stokes right but but that doesn't mean
that everyone has to be as
gung-ho about the stoke some people
might resonate more um
with uh some of the things the buddha
said some people might resonate more
with
what david pakman says you know like
like you you re
you really have to uh open up the space
that
uh that no one discovered the ultimate
truth
uh that works for everyone in all of
humanity
uh no one the stoics didn't uh certainly
um now what it could be an interesting
question
is what which philosophy is closest to
the science
is close to actually what the science
shows is most likely to lead to a good
life
that's a reasonable question and what's
the answer to that one
oh boy i've never answered that in
public before
um because i'm very wary of uh
you know in some sort of like uh fight
saying there's the winner
but i think that there are
the science shows that there's uh there
are grains of truth in all of them
i know that might sound like a bit of a
cop-out answer but it does need to
yeah it does i know right but you have
to like
mix and match you know um so
if if i was well actually that's what i
tried to do in my book transcend to be
honest is i didn't
pit it to a particular um uh
ancient philosophy uh i tried to present
a for integrated framework of what all
the science looks like
so my preferred approach is
science my preferred approach is to
uh to take the what we know about and
put together into an integrated
scientific framework as opposed to a
philosophical framework that's untested
now
that might be fighting words to some
philosophers but
about a philosopher i'm a psychologist
there are people who will no doubt
listen to this conversation and they'll
say guys you're missing the boat this
is not about maslow this is not about
stoicism there is no way
that anybody can really
self-actualize and transcend unless we
deal with
the structural problems in society when
we have some people might point to
neoliberalism
others will point to capitalism some
will point to the military-industrial
complex or inequality
and they will say what you're doing is
like a retail strategy but unless you do
the wholesale first
you're not going to get there what would
you say to that argument
well i think it's funny that you use the
word boat because that's my new uh
higher give needs metaphor as a sailboat
so
i i very much take in into account and
appreciate the fact that we can't have
too many holes in our boat or
we can't too much insecurity or too much
stressors
on on the boat itself for us we're not
going to go anywhere but i also try to
point
to the fact that we must not neglect our
higher possibilities either
so this is very much in the spirit of
what maslow talked about and i'm really
trying to bring back
a lot of these ideas and make the
argument that we need to work on both we
need to work on security and we also
need to work on growth
if you get too stuck in talking about uh
secure insecurity and uh and
you know safe spaces and um and and
systemic oppress all these things
which are fair enough
but if we talk too much about it we can
start to neglect
and forget that there's still beauty in
the world we can start to forget that
there's still
opportunities no matter what how dire
your current circumstances are
there are still opportunities for
meaning making there are opportunities
for connection
in fact if you if you get too caught up
in what maslow called the deficiency
realm of human existence
and neglect the b realm or the being
realm the growth realm
you actually start neglecting all these
amazing opportunities for connection
that may exist
because you're so focused on grievances
that actually strikes me a little as
maybe one of the aspects of stoic
philosophy that really applies which is
thinking about
the dichotomy or really the trichotomy
of control which is
while certainly it is true that some of
these systemic factors
impact our lives on a day-to-day basis
our ability to influence them is
dramatically more limited than our
mindset
our goals etc and so that would be a
very
pragmatic approach to distinguishing the
two
i would love you to unpack that a little
bit more well in the sense that
the for for example if we believe
that we are not as happy as we could be
both
because we have set goals for ourselves
that
are uh counterproductive and and make us
less happy
and because of inequality
at the broad economic level our ability
to
impact the latter is far more limited i
mean certainly we can say
i want to be the best activist i can so
that our elected officials reduce income
inequality but ultimately
the ability of one person to influence
that is is relatively limited
our ability to say i'm going to set
different goals for myself in my life
that is something we control entirely
and
and and can immediately use potentially
to improve our level of satisfaction
so that's a great point and i would say
that's you know you link that to stocism
i would also say that's
quite in common with a lot of the others
as well so maybe the ones that are
you keep cropping up over again in
different philosophies we start to get
it
the truth you know the generalizable
truth i would say that's a very core
part of humanistic psychology as well
i do think that change does start from
within and that is a big part of the
book
is talking about getting your ship in
order in a lot of ways
and that includes self-esteem that
includes having a healthy
uh sense of self-worth that doesn't
constantly need validation from others
you know i wrote an article for
scientific american on
uh uh the latest social science of the
victimhood mindset
and i try to put forward a better way in
that article
a a way that a better mindset that
that i think is you know that clinical
psychologists would
would would would rally around you know
where we don't have experiential
avoidance but where we
uh we have a sense of exploration and
curiosity and openness
for the world um we can still absolutely
fight for
um for injustices and there are real
victims
but the victimhood identity that's
something
that that i don't think people realize
especially if they've been socialized to
think that that's the only way to live
their life
i don't think a lot of people realize
that there's actually like you don't
have to make it
the core essential all uh main
overriding
part of your whole being one of the
things that's so interesting interesting
to me about that is
on the political spectrum some there are
certainly voices on the left that agree
with you
but the american right has made a big
deal out of
uh let's let's stop the victimhood
complex
let's stop all of this stuff and
meanwhile
they love and agree with donald trump's
four years of saying
he has been the most unfairly treated
president in history yesterday at a
rally
it's it's an incredible irony that at a
rally yesterday trump
said i've been treated worse than abe
lincoln remember abe lincoln was
assassinated i'm sure you remember
um and the crowd goes wild cheering you
know and the
the the uh incongruous nature of that
has been
very interesting to watch well i'll tell
you what else has been interesting to
watch with that phenomenon because i
i've done a lot of research on
narcissism and that forms a big part of
this book as well there's a whole
chapter on
the difference between self-esteem and
narcissism because they're different
they're very different they have
different developmental pathways
they have different correlates people
with a healthy self-esteem
[Applause]
it tends to be an outgrowth or an
outcome of
real earned accomplishment and um
connection with others
you know being a valued social member of
society
that's people with a healthy self-esteem
it comes as a result of that whereas
narcissism
is not something that's an emergent
property it's the driver you know
it's the thing that makes its will onto
the world
people with healthy self-esteem don't
feel the need to assert
their will and completely control and
change the world so there's so many
levels of irony that i that i've watched
unfold
in in in this administration which uh
from a narcissist
a grandiose narcissism perspective has
um
been fat i've been taking notes because
it's like you know i've published papers
on this topic and then i'm like oh my
gosh i'm seeing something that fits
my data like you know it validates my
career of research on this
yeah i think it will be it will prove to
be a treasure trove of data for study
for uh psychologists sociologists
mental health professionals of different
kinds it's really going to be a
remarkable thing to study for some time
the book is transcend the new science
of self-actualization we've been
speaking with the book's author
scott barry kaufman always great having
you on and i so appreciate your time
thanks for having me on and next time
let's talk about intelligence yes